oh hi how are you che torkoal it's
rhetorical it's rhetorical hi my name is
grace helbig if you didn't know I make
this [ __ ] I went on my Facebook page to
ask you guys what did you want to see
reviewed and or learn how to do and more
than one of you said that you want to
see the men of the Bachelorette reviewed
by me and that is great I wanted to do
it anyway and you just enabled me thank
you enablers get the best kind of people
it did not know the Bachelorette is a
game show about love in which a bunch of
men compete for the attention and
affection and possible engagement of one
single woman it's riveting their love
lasts as long as a teenager's attention
span to a youtube video I haven't
watched any of this season but that's
not gonna stop me from making this video
and made a video like this I think for
the contestants on The Bachelor which
was women competing for a man a we here
in the States give every gender the
opportunity to do a little themselves on
national television and now it's time to
turn that devil sign and dildo around
and review the men on The Bachelorette
common colloquialism here in the States
also a couple little um pieces of
information if you're new this is all
well-intentioned not mean-spirited you
probably do this in your head so I
donate to everyone you pass on the
street anyway and this might not make
any sense welcome to the grace Helbig
youtube channel Alex Alex looks like his
right shoulder deflated from wanking it
very athletic but he's got a great smile
which leads me to believe that he
probably has stuck a toothbrush in his
the whole before Ali Ali looks like he
will pee in your pool he will pee in
your pool and he's not trying to be
funny about it
it's an issue Brandon Oh Brandon I just
feel bad for Brandon why do I feel so
bad for Brandon Brandon looks a little
bit like Josh we really ready face more
Chad Chad looks a little bit like it
puts on lady bikinis at parties thinking
it's like a fun joke for everyone and
everyone's like
and it's okay if you just like where
Rehman's the communities chase chase
looks like the kind of guy that learned
to kiss using like a trumpet Christian
Christians had a ball fall out in the
wrong place but he tried holy oh he
looks like he loves steers loves it
what's his hobby you just said none all
the ride-on mowers at Sears
Derek don't leave Derek alone in the
kitchen with the banana bread you ruined
Christmas Daniel Daniel looks like the
kind of guy that's afraid of putting on
turtlenecks Evan Evan website a kind of
guy after a glass of wine just wants to
lay out some blank canvases and paint
with his weiner grant grant say the kind
of guy that still has never seen
Brokeback Mountain but like whenever
it's brought up and some sort of like
really misogynistic way he's just like
huh Jake Jake looks fun
unless he's not James F James F looks
like a forever DD he's reliable he's got
that Bob Vila style
James s James S blows ah he's ready to
SMD why you over human eraser James
Taylor what an unfortunate name James
Taylor looks like the kind of guy that
loves talking about how when you're
super drunk he looks like Chris Pratt
cousin adopted cousin Jonathan John
onside kind of guys always got a little
bit peanut butter stuck on the roof now
Jordan you know he's not the newest kid
on the block but keep he sort of knows
where the block is Lou Luke looks like
he would not know when the party's over
everyone is leaving Luke you have to go
and Luke would be like you said
breakfast tacos Nick B it feels like the
kind of guy that loved that Miley Cyrus
wrecking ball music video but just truly
love the wrecking ball not the song or
Miley Cyrus he just likes Google search
and heavy machinery Nick s Nick asked
looks like the kind of guy that like
truly fantasizes about Scary Spice Peter
Peters more
baby spice kind of guy Robbie Robbie
looks like he's the kind of guy that's
just real desperate for you to tell me
what's anything like Bradley Cooper sow
pals got some gastrointestinal issues
can't tell if it's an artistic
background in this photo just like smoke
from a egg apart Vinnie
he looks like the kind of guy that even
if he was being arrested he would try to
continue to like bulbous butts on
Instagram well whales might actually be
family bro Gilmore Girls
what oh all of the feelings well well
looks like the kind of guy that like
shows up at the party is like a fun
uncle and you thought it'd be like
really fun to like crush a beer bottle
on his head and then on his nephew said
but then his nephew is like a newborn
and doesn't have a fully formed head yet
and everyone was like well there you go
there are some of my completely unbiased
and completely just random assessments
of the contestants on this season of The
Bachelorette we're any of them close or
were they all completely off you do it
thanks for sticking around to this part
of the video if you like this video give
it a thumbs up and please over to
subscribe to this channel it would mean
a lot to me in the feeling sense of
things other than that I don't know you
got a nice mom you've experiment with a
DB in your BH toothbrush in your bundle
that sounds like a country song